i want us to be the anomaly the anti-boy
band it's an elevated version of us
whatever you saw before it's like that
one steroids it's cool being a dad it's
super fun super rewarding i love it
well we're writing about love still
obviously yeah
okay who's in love who's in love so
i i want to kind of start things off by
talking about
2020 um it's been a wild time for
everybody and
you guys have been quarantined together
what did you guys do at home to keep
yourselves you know
feeling light hearty did you pick up any
new skills like i was just picking up
guitar again
um i built a computer like i was just we
just
started doing things that you can have
more time in your hands yeah
so much time on our hands in quarantine
randomly i started just reading books
so like so far just this year i've read
like eight books and i've never even
read books before so that was like a
weird
unexpected like hobby that i picked up
like i really didn't expect it but i
enjoy it now i actually started taking
some like online courses because i was
like screw it like i mean i got like
tons of free time in my hand
might as well hit the books a little
more what class
uh right now it's just like liberal arts
like
associates in liberal arts so i just
take online classes
to get that degree eventually at some
point in the beginning
of quarantine i i bought a computer so
that i can
um get into just more like graphic
designing and like
3d rendering so that when there is a
time that we can apply those skills
hopefully one day like we could do the
tour visuals and i could like make all
these 3d
visuals for tour and we don't have to
you know outsource for that kind of
stuff
austin i know you've had uh your hands
full
in the best way possible with your
little boy theo how is fatherhood going
yeah so that that happened during
quarantine he was born on the the 27th
come to may 27 and um
it was it was crazy everything just
changed for me like
the way i view the world and myself and
everything
so i i got i got i feel very blessed in
the sense that i i knew i had time to
spend with my son at a young age
how is little theo and how is it being a
dad
it's cool being that i think it's um you
know
it's super rewarding you i feel like you
learn a lot more about yourself
when you have a tiny you
learning and developing you start to be
like oh i i
had like this subconscious memory of me
doing something like that when i was
that little like it just pulls things
out of you
um it's super fun super rewarding i i
love it he's he's great he could be
healthier and
you know he's super easy he's super
chill
my favorite because awesome every time
he comes up to the house he always
brings him so we see him like when he's
come
when he first gets here and then when he
leaves and he's always just
kicking it he's just chilling he's
kicking it he's giggling and he's like
looking around super curious
okay be real who's theo's favorite uncle
oh
so cute um i know he's really little but
do you ever play him your music get a
reaction out of him
hey so i i play music for him
um i'm very particular about what i play
for him right now i'm
kind of keeping it to um very classical
music
and like light jazz and that kind of
stuff because it helps
um developmental stages yeah but i i
mean he's heard our music because
i'm like listening to it he just happens
to be in the room
i love it i think i think listening to
pretty much at an early age
will only mean that he will go on to do
great things
just kind of on a more serious note guys
it's um it's been
it's been a year i'm curious what kind
of effect
this year has had on you personally and
maybe if you've
you feel like you've learned or grown it
kind of
opened my eyes to realize how much like
influence we actually do have
because i don't think that our role is
to influence an opinion
whether it is to actually influence
someone to
educate themselves so to be able to form
an opinion um
because now more than ever i feel like
we just need more people to be
awake i think this year was a big year
for i don't know if maturity is the
right word but like a different level of
like respect of like
just like like life you know even just
with our fans like
the the barrier that there is now
between us between and our fans like
i'm really more now than ever not just
not that we weren't grateful before but
like it's you know being deprived of
being able to see
our fans has made it more like now it's
like i'm
looking forward to that yeah to be in a
situation where we can perform for them
right right and do fan events i think we
needed this whole year to kind of just
learn and to find ourselves a little bit
and now it's i feel like it's just set
us up
for what was about to come and it's
now it's getting exciting again you
bring up your fans and of course
you know it's challenging i include
myself i am a fan it's it's challenging
when you know we're so used to seeing
you guys all over social media
and you kind of put a pause on that um
why was it necessary for you guys to
kind of take a little
social media break i feel like it was
just a good way for us to just kind of
like take a step back
and like look at ourselves look at like
what we want like where
where we are where we want to go what we
want to do
so like i feel like it just kind of gave
us like a good like a big big reset
and i feel like it was it was hard so i
got on the fans a little bit because
they were like oh we want more we want
more but we're like
we promise you like this is this is well
needed but when the time comes
yeah like you'll be like you'll be like
okay
this is like worth the wait was there
any part of you that was
like fearful like oh my gosh are we
alienating the fans too much
um like are you reading reactions on
social media
we definitely see it but it's also
important to realize that
you know everybody is human um and
although that we we have these fans and
they love us to death right
like we know that they love us enough
to know that when we do take time to
reflect that they'll be there for us
um but i'm always you know i'm the same
way when it comes like frank ocean right
like i love him to death and the minute
that i
you know i'm dying for him to drop an
album when i'm dying for him but i think
it's like
as much to have um fear
that like he might not come back i have
so much more hope that he will drop
music soon you know i mean we just tip
our hats to them because they've been
here for so long and they really have
been holding
on for so long and it means the world to
us that they really care this much too
so you guys huge congratulations
i believe you have a little announcement
that you'd like to share
oh it's lit we do we are finally uh
signed with sire records under warner
records so
yes we're very excited for that very
excited we're
excited for this pretty much 2.0 you
know we really need to
make sure um big reset for us you know
perspective vision look sound
everything intention everything so
keeping it
true to us true to us yeah and uh now
that we're
in this new deal we are definitely
dropping music soon
it's gonna be crazy we got music ready
okay i have a bajillion questions about
all the new music and all the exciting
things that you're working on what is
this new era of pretty much what is it
going to look like what is it going to
sound like what is it going to feel like
more advanced that's more about the work
i always keep saying it just feels
natural and authentic and real and fun
um and yeah the music is really going to
speak for that and
everything else is really going to speak
for that we're going to have this
hopeful ballad
we're going to have the songs that you
throw on the party we're going to have
the songs that you
just want to dance to and you can't stop
and help but fidget in the car you know
what i mean
like all that all that's going to be
there but it's just going to be
exactly what we envisioned when we first
got together as a group
i remember there was like a night we all
sat down and like just came up with
concepts it's going to be all that stuff
that we originally came up with
like so unconditionally ourselves you
know unconditionally ourselves
right just super next level
let me ask about your songwriting
process i know songwriting is important
to you guys
um who is sitting down what are you
writing about what's inspiring you is it
a certain person or
people or is there something that
happened in your life we're kind of like
basically hyping each other up which is
which is really really fun like a lot of
some of these songs you know
were first started off by me or by zion
or if i brand in there
or an idea stemmed and then we developed
that idea from there
i hear something zion's doing in the
room and i go yo bro that's dope we
should we should develop that or brandon
starts something and plays it out and
we're like yo
let's go in on that right versus trying
to find
the song whereas that was that was the
struggle that we were
for like the last three years is we're
trying to find this hit we're trying to
find
sure these records right whereas we just
kind of let them happen
so can you share like specific things
that you're writing about
love um we're writing about
let's see which one i thought we're
writing about love still obviously
you know it's in the air
okay who's in love who's in love i mean
me obviously i'm always involved
when you're creating music how do you
guys decide who is going to sing which
part
i think sometimes some parts feel like
almost no one has to say anything like
we just know who's going to sing it
because
like whether brandon's saying the demo
on it he just i'm so good on the demo
that it's like that's definitely his
part or like i've been singing part of
the demo it's like oh that's definitely
edward's part like
and sometimes edward will sing a demo
and i hear nick i'm like oh yeah nick
would kill that like you know what i
mean
and sometimes we all do all the parts
and then compete differently and
whatever sounds the best but um we know
each other so well it's it's almost like
it's we don't even have to like talk to
each other we can just all look at each
other alright
and sometimes my favorite ones are the
ones where
like someone wrote a specific part of
the song so they have to use that part
because it's true to them there's a song
where i'm not going to sing that part or
try that part because it's literally
literally it's not even true to me it's
true to die on or it's true to
brandon well that makes sense is there a
favorite
lyric that you guys have ever written
uh looking for you like a parking spot
oh no the light bulb yeah yeah yeah she
sucked all the life out of me lipo
that's my favorite oh wait wait wait
wait also
um i know you guys have dabbled in
producing some of your own stuff in the
past is that something you will be doing
more in the future there's like two that
i produced by myself and then there's
one that edwin produced and then
one of our friends kylo produced um
obviously lido mahomey he
co-produced but what's important to note
is that although
you know some records started with other
producers
um we try to have at least i mean it's
mainly the majority of the time brandon
because he's
but like we have we have to have him
sprinkle his sauce
all over all the songs even if he
doesn't start it because
he ultimately understands the sonic of
what pretty much is
it's like you share one brain i love
that so much you guys trust
brandon that much um you know we've been
blessed to have three
pretty much eps the fans are crossing
every finger toe that will get a proper
album is that in the works it is always
in the works yes
most yeah i think for the thing that i
keep saying too
is that like you know i'm grateful that
we haven't
had our debut album because like i keep
saying it's like we're just now
this feels like the start this feels
like everything was like pre-season and
into
like such a learning curve and like we
had you know we got to do so many things
and experience but
ultimately it taught us a lot and it
gave us it helped us
helped us to define like the things we
did want the things we didn't want
it's like it was like before we were
playing college basketball now we're
now we're in the nba yeah yeah yeah now
the real game begins
the album is coming but it's it's good
to know on our end that
it's gonna be our debut album still
you know have you started brainstorming
what you're going to call it
no that comes last once we have
everything together
does it ever blow your mind that without
even putting out a proper
debut album that you guys are already at
this this level that you're at
yeah it's crazy it's crazy it's great
that you say that
i don't know oh yeah i'd be forgetting
especially like with this year like
sometimes i forget that i'm i'm in the
public eye an
artist um yeah so it is it's really nice
to see that um
everyone's still sticking with us it's
gonna be so worth it
this is the craziest [ __ ] you'll ever
hear i promise you
as you can as you can hear zion's pretty
humble uh
i'm not kidding like no one's like
there's not there's no better music in
the industry i think the most important
part is
that like if we if we like if we have
like
true fans and they really love us and
they really care about us
like they're not going anywhere just
kind of like us if we care about them
no matter how long it's gonna take we
we're still here we're not going nowhere
[Music]
you know the fans are gonna be so ready
when the world opens
up to see you guys out on tour are there
tour
plans in the works and what is your live
show going to be like with this
new era of pretty much when we are ready
to tour again
you best believe it's going to be i mean
i crave it
we always say our tour if you come to
our tour experience
and see what we have to offer like
that's our best foot forward we're so
so incredibly hands-on like um and we'll
continue to be
for every other tour in the future but i
think the biggest thing is that we're
always stepping it up
expect as always if you've been to a
show a lot of energy
a lot of dancing get ready to sweat
get ready you know it's gonna be a it's
a party every time
austin have you thought about what going
on the road is gonna look like for you
i mean is is baby theo gonna be like the
most
badass like groupie roadie with you on
on tour
i thought about it a lot i feel like um
for me
i have this very specific outlook on how
i want to be as a father
who's also um a performer an entertainer
a songwriter
you know all that stuff i i don't want
to put my son in so much
light right in the beginning and almost
make a decision for his life pat before
he can even speak
i think that's kind of crazy so um he
won't go on tour until he can talk and
be like that i want to go on tour
yeah yeah i mean like that'll be the
time when it happens but
you know he's still young he's still a
baby he the tour was not a place for him
you know what i mean
and not to say that he won't come out
and see a show or two you know
maybe the la show or something
uh is he influencing at all the way that
you're approaching music austin the way
that you think about songwriting or
the type of music that you want to be
doing everything i live
and everything i do and everything i
think kind of
gears the way that i would write as an
artist you know or
paint or whatever it is that i'm doing
you know there's always that
your experiences guide what you create
so
yeah that most definitely would you guys
mind each of you contributing like a
dream collaboration or
i don't know even someone that you've
like slid into dms like i i've got to
work with you i think we'd be
like magical together i want to work
with rosalia
maybe jeremiah when he gets better you
know he's he's hurting right now but
prayers
i work with travis scott
i just love travis scott so it would be
sick to have travis scott
in our corner i i love elijah's last
project he just put out and
how he's taken on the persona of being a
dad now too
i'm into all the dad rappers
nicole yeah that's my boss this is brent
it's my brand name
miley cyrus good country song with her
wow that's actually a great point zion
are you guys going to be expanding the
genres
uh that you're that you're singing like
can we get country undertones in pretty
much
if it's a good song let's drop it if one
day we're like yo
this song is crunchy but it's fire like
why not
let's just do it we want to just genre
ben i think it's so important that we
always have some kind of glue
that keeps it together but you know we
want to go and hit these different
things you know i want us to be the
anomaly like the and
the anti-boy band like the like we do
all the things that
aren't supposed to work but they work
because it's under it's authentic it's
undeniable
it's like we're doing our best and we're
having fun like that's what matters
brandon you just bring up you know you
kind of want to be the anti-boy band is
the the label or the phrase boy band
um frustrating or aggravating to you or
do you guys embrace it
oh no i say everywhere i go if anyone
asks me what i do i say i'm gonna boy
yeah
and i think too now with the whole just
being in the new label
the word boy band hasn't even been a
conversation right
it's all about the artistry and the
music well that is the term that you
you your your brain thinks of when you
see us right yeah but at the end of the
day we're a
group that makes music yeah totally and
i know you're a dope group making some
fire music videos zion i'm looking at
you i've been following you on social
media you've been
sharing these little snippets and clips
what have you been filming
how wild is it tell me everything it's
lots of fun
dancing um
just like yeah it's just an elevated
version of us whatever you saw before
it's like that
one steroids yeah we're taking a huge
artsy approach to doing some of these
videos
yeah and that's away from what does that
mean like
just like vegetables like very creative
artistic like
like if you were painting instead of
doing like a normal portrait painting
it's like we're doing abstract like
splatter of color all over like
psychedelic kind of like
vibes you know what i'm saying like it's
it's in that world
you guys have me real hype for 2021 are
there any dates that you can share when
fans can really expect to hear like a
single
or an album announcement very top of the
year very very top of the year
very good well we'll be announcing yeah
yeah
okay very top of the year lots of
goodies for fans
my last question to you is just when the
fans hear
this new era of pretty much how do you
want them to react how do you want them
to feel
that everyone has a [ __ ] great time
and everyone has a good time that's
i think i think people are going to be
surprised
that we were able to do what we did we
did it you know
i feel like i feel like everyone's just
going to be like listening with just
drawn
jaw dropping yeah just like
like you produce it like what wait this
is pretty
this is pretty much pretty much this is
yeah what
it would give me great happiness knowing
that
our music you know for people coming out
of 2020
is something that brings them new hope
and happiness and joy
um that they didn't have throughout this
last year brandon my last question is
for you
you've got a big birthday coming up how
are you going to celebrate
all right i'm going to pour 1942. we're
gonna get him drunk
here's my 21st i don't know yet i don't
know but we'll do
i'm maybe they'll do something we'll go
to vegas
we'll see
you